[Música]
mientras países nórdicos se acercan a la
otan la región separatista de georgia
osetia del sur ratificó su intención de
realizar un referéndum para integrarse a
rusia un deseo similar han expresado
provincias ucranianas como gerson done y
skip edwards
a dos semanas de los comicios
presidenciales en colombia el alcalde de
medellín fue suspendido por respaldar al
candidato izquierdista gustavo petro el
funcionario afirmó que llevara su caso a
la comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos
y las feministas estadounidenses siguen
rechazando la posible derogación del
derecho al aborto en el país en esta
emisión les contaremos la historia de
varias de las mujeres que serían las más
violentadas si se prohíbe la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
mi nombre es maría clara calle y es un
placer acompañarlos iniciamos este
informativo en ucrania donde se llevó a
cabo el primer juicio por crímenes de
guerra las autoridades están juzgando a
un soldado ruso de 21 años por ser el
presunto asesino de un civil desarmado
que iba en bicicleta en la región de
summit el hecho se produjo justo después
de la invasión rusa quien acusó a moscú
de repetidas atrocidades en ucrania y
los fiscales dicen que están
investigando más de 10.000 posibles
crímenes de guerra veamos el informe
es el primer soldado ruso en ser juzgado
por cometer un crimen de guerra badín sí
sí marín de 21 años está acusado de
asesinar a un civil ucraniano desarmado
mientras montaba en bicicleta según los
fiscales el sargento ruso disparó al
hombre de 62 años en la cabeza a través
de la ventanilla abierta del vehículo el
incidente tuvo lugar en el pueblo
nororiental de chip aquí acá en la
región de summit justo después del
inicio de la guerra el abogado de sisi
marín dijo que el caso contra su cliente
es fuerte y que aún no había decidido
cómo se declarara el surf se entregó por
su cuenta todas las demás cuestiones
están relacionadas con el procedimiento
material y penal todo esto serán
audiencias posteriores él dará todas las
respuestas a todas estas cuestiones
cuando declare o no
si es condenado se enfrenta a una pena
de hasta cadena perpetua el caso es
extremadamente importante para quienes
ya que las autoridades presionan para
que rusia rinda cuentas por lo que
escriben como atrocidades inimaginables
llevadas a cabo por las fuerzas rusas
los fiscales dicen que están
investigando más de 10.000 posibles
crímenes de guerra que implican a más de
600 sospechosos
el kremlin continúa negando haber
atacado a civiles y acusa a 10 de
organizar ataques como parte de los
esfuerzos para desprestigiar a las
tropas rusas
y en medio de la guerra en el este de
europa varios países como suecia y
finlandia se están acercando a la otan
mientras que otras zonas apuestan por
una integración con rusia es el caso de
osetia del sur una región separatista de
georgia que mostró su intención de
realizar un referéndum de integración a
la federación rusa un deseo similar
tienen regiones ucranianas como gerson
donges y lugansk las fronteras rusas
podrían extenderse en los próximos meses
el presidente de facto de la región
separatista de georgia osetia del sur
anunció este viernes que organizara el
próximo 17 de julio un referéndum sobre
su adhesión a rusia hoy el decreto del
referéndum ha sido firmado por el
presidente en el lenguaje de la ley
hemos cumplido otro requisito legal muy
importante y el lenguaje del pueblo
hemos dado un paso trascendental nos
vamos a casa nos vamos a rusia el 17 de
julio del 2022 se celebrará un
referéndum sobre la unificación de
osetia del sur y rusia osetia del sur
fue el centro de la guerra entre georgia
y en 2008 tras la cual rusia reconoció
su independencia junto con asia y donde
tiene desde entonces bases militares
georgia no reconoce la región como
independiente y calificó de inaceptable
el proyecto otras regiones de ucrania
también podrían pronunciarse sobre su
adhesión a rusia como gerson sabor y ya
lugares y dones que un responsable pro
ruso de gerzón una de las primeras
ciudades en caer en manos rusas reafirmó
este miércoles que pedirá a rusia su
integración al país un proyecto que teme
ucrania porque nos dice el enemigo está
llevando a cabo los preparativos para un
supuesto referéndum sobre la adhesión de
los territorios ocupados en las regiones
de ejerció niza polilla a la federación
rusa derecha el kremlin dijo que
respetará la voluntad del pueblo de
gerson program
como por supuesto la existencia o no de
tal recurso para unirse a rusia debe ser
decidida por los residentes de la región
de gerzón y el destino de la región de
gerzón también debe ser determinado por
sus residentes
con el transcurso de la guerra y gracia
podría haberse reorganizada
geopolíticamente con rusia y la otan
como protagonistas
vamos a américa un alcalde colombiano
fue sancionado y llevará a su caso ante
la comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos se trata de daniel quintero el
alcalde de la ciudad de medellín esta
semana del público un vídeo por el cual
se le acusa de respaldar a la campaña
presidencial del izquierdista gustavo
petro la procuraduría que es la entidad
encargada de sancionar
disciplinariamente a los funcionarios
consideró que quintero estaba
participando en política y lo suspendió
de su cargo el alcalde se defendió
diciendo que la procuraduría está
alineada con los intereses del gobierno
el caso se produce dos semanas antes de
las elecciones presidenciales se ha
iniciado ya hemos iniciado hoy que
constituye un equipo jurídico ahorita
el doctor héctor que al bajar va a
definir a decidir cuáles son las
acciones particulares que se han
emprender héctor hace parte del equipo
de defensa ante los organismos
nacionales pero tenemos un equipo
internacional que acaba de mostrar y que
está preparando los alegatos que van a
ser enviados el día de hoy que va a
mostrar como la procuradora ciudad alió
con el gobierno nacional en una misma
línea política de poder político el
mismo partido para poder sacar a los
líderes y podrá poder excluir a los
líderes que hacen parte de otra orilla
ideológica las autoridades colombianas
enviaron a paraguay el cuerpo del fiscal
contra el crimen organizado marcelo
pecci quien fue asesinado el pasado 10
de mayo en la isla colombiana de barú
mientras celebraba su luna de miel ph
investigaba varios casos relacionados
con el crimen transnacional y el crimen
organizado en paraguay previamente
conversamos con jeremy mcdermott
codirector ejecutivo y cofundador de
insightcrime a quien le preguntamos
sobre cómo se vincula el narcotráfico de
paraguay con el del resto de américa
latina
es para y es el principal productor de
marihuana de américa del sur y la mayor
parte de su producción es para el
mercado de brasil con respecto a la
cocaína
pues eso esto narcotráfico es como el
agua y va por el cómico al camino de
menor resistencia y hay muy poca
resistencia en paraguay entonces cocaína
de perú y bolivia pasa por paraguay
hacia brasil que tiene un consumo
interno muy alto y asia de europa
y una de las mayores incautaciones de
cocaína en europa del año pasado de 11
toneladas en el puerto de amberes en
bélgica se originó en paraguay las
feministas estadounidenses continúan
manifestándose en contra de lo que
podría ser la derogación del derecho al
aborto en el país la discusión pública
no ha cesado desde que se filtró un
borrador de sentencia de la corte
suprema que aparentemente anularía la
decisión del caso roe versus wait que
garantiza el derecho al aborto en eeuu
desde 1973 víctimas de abusos sexuales
exponen sus casos para visibilizar el
retroceso marina sardenya nos cuentan
de beta tenía 16 años y soñaba con
entrar al ejército cuando un reclutador
la violó quedó embarazada de su agresor
pero pudo acceder a un aborto gracias al
derecho que le otorgaba la sentencia roe
versus wade
quedé embarazada como resultado de una
violación y simplemente decidí que no
quería cuidar al niño o incluso tener el
bebé porque simplemente no estaba en el
estado emocional adecuado para tener un
hijo que vino de una violación
de informar y su historia es una más
entre las miles de mujeres que han sido
víctimas de agresiones sexuales en eeuu
y que tras ello decidieron abortar
teniendo así una segunda oportunidad una
vida más digna ahora ellas alzan la voz
contando sus casos para denunciar como
la eventual prohibición de la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
pondría en vilo los derechos
reproductivos de las mujeres del país 20
por ciento que la corte suprema no es el
lugar para tomar una decisión sobre mi
cuerpo en el mapa de la penalización del
aborto discrimina aún más a las mujeres
de contextos vulnerables o de
comunidades afro indígenas inmigrantes
poniendo en riesgo sus vidas después de
que fracasara un intento por codificar
el derecho al aborto en el senado este
viernes los demócratas llamaron a los
estadounidenses a defender el aborto
sobre liverpool en círculos republicanos
de todo el país ya se están movilizando
en torno a una agenda peligrosa y
extrema para criminalizar todas las
formas de atención sanitaria
reproductiva incluyendo la ive la
anticoncepción y la atención post aborto
sin escala richter las activistas
feministas están organizando marchas
masivas en cuatro ciudades del país
nueva york chicago los ángeles y
washington y movilizaciones hasta el
verano cuando se espera se conozca el
fallo del tribunal supremo que daría a
los estados la potestad de decidir
individualmente sus políticas con
respecto al aborto llegamos al final de
las noticias los invitamos a que sigan
conectados con france24
[Música]